do you see a future of
uh where like robots are in our home
and in the like robots that
have like um actuators that look like
arms
in our home or like you know more like
humanoid type robots
or is this are we gonna is we're gonna
do the same thing that you just
mentioned that
you know the dishwasher is no longer a
robot we're going to just
not even see them as robots but do i
mean what's your
vision of the home of the future 10 20
years from now
50 years if you get crazy yeah i think
we already have roombas cruising around
we have
uh you know alexas or google homes on
their our
kitchen counter it's only a matter of
time till they spring arms and start
doing something
useful like that um so
i do think it's coming i think it's lots
of people have lots of motivations
for doing it it's been super interesting
actually learning about
toyota's vision for it which is about
helping people age in place
because i think that's not necessarily
the first entry the most lucrative
entry point but it's the problem maybe
that
we really need to solve no matter what
and
so i think i think there's a real
opportunity it's a delicate
problem how do you work with people help
people
keep them active engaged you know
but improve their quality of life and uh
and and help them age in place for
instance
it's interesting because older folks are
also
i mean there's a contrast there because
um
they're not always the the folks who are
the most comfortable technology for
example
so there's a there's a there's a
division that's interesting there that
you can do so much good with a robot
for for uh older folks
but there's a there's a gap to feel
of understanding i mean it's actually
kind of beautiful
robot is learning about the human and
the human is kind of learning about this
new robot thing and it's uh uh also with
um
at least with uh like when i talk to my
parents about robots there's a little
bit of a
blank slate there too like
you can i mean they don't know anything
about robotics
so it's completely like wide open
they don't have that they haven't my
parents haven't seen black mirror
so like they they there's it's a blank
slate here's a cool thing like what can
you do for me
yeah so it's an exciting space i think
it's a really important space
i do feel like you know a few years ago
uh drones were successful enough in
academia they kind of
broke out and started in industry and
autonomous cars
have been happening it does feel like
manipulation
uh in logistics of course first but
in the home shortly after seems like one
of the next big things that's going to
really
pop
you